bienvenue c'est l'heure de parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec onuora qui dit bonjour là bonjour
michael moore à tous alors entravé chefs
d'état mise en examen et un ministre qui
démissionnent la semaine a été marqué
par des décisions de justice qui ont
forcément un impact sur la vie politique
le parquet de paris ouvre une enquête
pour blanchiment de fraude fiscale
contre jérôme cahuzac le président de la
république n'a pas traîné jérôme cahuzac
débarquer jeu de chaises musicales au
gouvernement
c'est bernard cazeneuve alors aux
affaires européennes qui le remplace
puis jeudi coûte tonnerre pour l'ancien
président de la république après avoir
été confronté aux membres du personnel
de la milliardaire liliane bettencourt
nicolas sarkozy est mis en examen pour
abus de faiblesse
l'entourage de l'ancien président monte
au créneau pour le défendre
et puis on l'aurait presque oublié mais
cette semaine il ya eu une motion de
censure contre le gouvernement de face à
face à hull entre jean marc ayrault et
jean françois copé la motion de censure
a sans surprise été rejetée par
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre a profité de ce discours pour
fixer le cap et tenter de reprendre la
main sur sa majorité avec nous pour
commenter cette actualité jean
christophe cambadélis député socialiste
de paris merci d'être avec nous bonjour
on va évidemment revenir très vite sur
cette semaine politique qui prend les
allures d'une chronique judiciaire
abracadabrantesque aurait pu t'en dire
aussi mais on ne va pas déroger d'abord
à la coutume notre invité passe toujours
sous les fourches caudines de ses
collègues et camarades députés pour vous
aux quatre colonnes certains ont retenu
ça ne va pas vous étonner
ce petit côté critiques qui vous
caractérisent on écoute c'est quelqu'un
qui a
plus de qualités que d'utilité
aujourd'hui c'était dommage parce que je
pense qu'il peut jouer un rôle plus
constructif
c'est un des rares socialistes qui est
toujours une vision stratégique
c'est-à-dire qu'ils voient les choses
loin avant et loin devant il est surtout
connu pour quand il pense quelque chose
le dire de manière assez carré parfois
on peut juger que c'est trop parfois on
peut juger aussi que ça aussi une vertu
celle de la stimulation j'ai jamais eu
tellement de relations avec lui pour
être très honnête alors qu'à une époque
des on disait qu'il était chargé des
relations avec les autres partis
politiques au sein du ps
incontestablement un homme de parti mais
je dirai au meilleur sens du terme c'est
pas que ça quand on le connais bien
c'est un homme d'une grande sensibilité
d'une grande culture d'une grande
intelligence je ne sais pas ce qu'il
pense des écologistes il faudra lui
poser la question
en tout cas il ne pense pas que c'est
intéressant de discuter avec eux après
je sais que il était candidat pour
prendre la présence du ps aujourd'hui on
a par secrétaire général du ps qui est
particulièrement discret ce qui nous va
bien et là au moins une parole un peu
plus libre et je dirais même un peu plus
responsable donc pour nous c'est une
bonne nouvelle qui vient harlem désir
plutôt que jean christophe cambadélis là
pour comprendre les députés ump ce qu'on
a raté les épisodes précédents à vous
briguiez la tête du ps est harlem désir
qui l'a eu ça vous fait plaisir que des
députés ump comme ça considère que
harlem désir n'est pas bien dangereux et
qu'ils avaient plus à craindre de vous
ces deux dunks est un grand classique on
va dire on joue sur les contradictions
je pourrais dire que je me félicite que
ce soit copé est pas fillon qui dirige
l'ump pourquoi parce qu'il est plus
dangereux dans cendrillon mais c'est
revient au strictement au même nom c'est
une manière de jouer sur les difficultés
momentanées d'une formation politique
font sans les écologistes un peu amer
danseurs mais je crois qu'ils font une
erreur ce qui montre qu'ils ne
connaissent pas très bien le parti
socialiste c'est dans une autre vie que
je m'occupais des relations extérieures
du parti socialiste aujourd'hui je
m'occupe de l'international et de
l'europe
et c'est à l'époque de jospin et de
lagos plus rien donc on cassera la crau
part pour discuter par contre au parti
socialiste celui d'harlem désir
aujourd'hui revit que vous êtes un peu
le pompier pyromane
ça vous choque non je vous ai dit que je
serais le capitaine de route c'est à
dire vous savez dans le cyclisme c'est
celui qui applique les stratégies qui
gueule un peu quand on est en retard
dans une échappée qui capable de voir
les stratégies des adversaires et c'est
donc je fais mon travail je parle quand
j'estime que c'est nécessaire et quand
je pense que ça va pas très très bien
la semaine dernière j'ai parlé parce que
je sentais pas les choses et on a eu les
résultats dans l'oise
ce n'était pas formidable du point de
vue du parti socialiste qui dit tout ce
que tout le monde pense tout bas c'est
un peu ça est ce que il y a des limites
à ne pas franchir
ou est-ce que vous avez ternie des
quelques limites bien sûr vous m'avez
pas entendu critiquer l'action du
président de la république ni du
gouvernement
je vous avais dit qu'il parlait trop
c'est déjà une critique assez importante
mais on a oublié la deuxième partie de
la phrase c'est bien mais c'est bien
médiatique jeudi qu'il parlait trop
parce que c'était sa manière de rester
en dialogue avec les français donc ce
n'est pas une critique
ce que je pensais qu'il sait qu'il
devrait s qui va faire d'ailleurs
ramasser un moment donné son propos en
fixant et on repique sans le cap alors
esprit critique quand même que vous
allez pouvoir exercer sur cette semaine
d'actualité
et évidemment il y a eu un coup de
tonnerre cette semaine la mise en examen
nicolas sarkozy pour abus de faiblesse
dans l' affaire bettencourt le juge
gentil lui a signifié jeudi soir après
une longue audition et vendredi matin
l'entourage de nicolas sarkozy et est
monté au front
bien sûr pour le défendre en écoute pour
ce qui me concerne j'avoue ne pas
comprendre je le répète les motivations
de ce que je sais les motivations de
cette décision et donc je pense qu'il
vaut mieux
avant de commenter quoi que ce soit de
la retenue moi je n'ai aucun doute je
vous le dis sur l'innocence nicolas
sarkozy dans cette affaire et je vous le
dis nicolas sarkozy est à mille lieues
de tout cela aucun homme sensé dans ce
pays peut penser un instant que nicolas
sarkozy s'est livré sur cette vieille
dame richissime à un abus de faiblesse
c'est absolument grotesque alors ce
serait risible si ça ne s'agissait pas
l'honneur d'un homme qui a été président
de la république qui ayant été président
de la république entraîne dans ce set
salissures la france et la république
elle-même peut dire ce qu'a fait ce juge
est extrêmement grave vous savez dans la
république
quand on vous confie des responsabilités
des pouvoirs la l'année il ya une
nécessité absolue à ce que chacun les
exercent avec un sens aigu de la
responsabilité
ce qu'a fait le juge est extrêmement
grave dit henri guaino
moi je ne partage pas cette idée de
cette position pour défendre un homme
qui lisent en attaque et un autre chacun
est dans sa responsabilité bon voilà il
ya une enquête très sarkozy n'est plus
président de la république c'est un
citoyen comme les autres et on crierait
si on on savait que il devrait être mis
en examen qu'il ne laisserait pas à
cause du fait qu' il a été président de
la république donc je crois qu'il faut
garder raison
il ya l'indépendance de la justice elle
fait son travail
et puis chacun qu'un homme politique
comme ça met en cause le travail d'un
juge
c'est assez choquant mais c'est assez
compréhensible aussi parce que monsieur
guaino se voit en mousquetaire de
nicolas sarkozy ait fait don de son
corps au combat qui veut mener est bon
c'est pense le protéger je pense qu'il
ne le protège pas acquis le qui
l'affaiblît si on va un petit peu plus
loin est ce que par exemple statut pénal
du chef de l'état qui ne sera pas revu
finalement parce qu'on va revoir le
statut civil du chef de l'état c'est
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui avec ce
qu'on voit avec cette affaire de nicolas
sarkozy bien se remet encore une fois
dans le jeu politique
non puisque nicolas sarkozy l' affaire a
commencé on va dire il ya bien longtemps
mais elle ne touchait pas au point de
départ le président de la république
puisque c'est monsieur woerth qui était
au milieu de cette affaire ont par
ricochet on pouvait penser que mais il
n'y avait rien dans le dossier
visiblement qui impliquait le président
de la république et quand l'enquêté a
débouché sur le président de la
république
enfin sur l'ex président de la
république nicolas sarkozy il n'était
plus président de la république donc moi
je crois que bon c'est normal quand il y
à une affaire comme ça on va on
multiplie les interrogations les
discussions mais où c'est assez simple
il ya une enquête qui est menée elle
implique un moment donné non pas pour
l'accusé puisque le problème de cette
mise en examen c'est que dans la sphère
il ya des éléments concordants qui
tendrait à penser que mais ça veut pas
dire qu'il est coupable isation déjà qui
va décider vous imagine un futur chef
d'état budget de la faiblesse d'une
femme c'est l'argument qui est employé
on a entendu valérie pécresse
c'est vrai que c'est une mise en
accusation qui est grave quand même un
abus de faiblesse sur s'ils étaient
avérés ce serait extrêmement grave mais
rien nous permet parce que vous comme
nous personne n'est au courant du
dossier c'est le juge seul tia les
tenants et les aboutissants donc on veut
pas savoir s'il se trompe si le la au
delà de sa fonction
s'il fait s'il agit politiquement mais
moi on sera dans quelques temps le jour
où il y aura le procès en tant que tels
ces conseillers jean christophe
cambadélis
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous estimez qu'un
retour possible de nicolas sarkozy
serait impossible avec une mise en
examen
ecoutez jean c'est strictement rien ce
que je sais c'est que ça complique
encore plus la recomposition ou le louis
la reconstruction de l'ump parce que
nicolas sarkozy était clairement
candidat à être candidat à la
présidentielle il s'était avancé non
dans un interview de valeur la valeur
actuelle
et moi je pensais qu'à l'époque qu'il
impuissante et l'ump car l'ump ne peut
pas se reconstruire on l'a vu dans la
motion de censure d'ailleurs ils peuvent
à se reconstruire sans le faire le bilan
du sarkozysme et comme nicolas sarkozy
est candidat c'est très difficile de
faire le bilan du sarkozysme
donc il était déjà dans une situation
d'impasse mais là il va falloir qu'ils
attendent le résultat de l'enquète parce
que ça ne m'arrange pas ni françois
fillon des gens contre je crois que ça
n'arrange pas l'ump qui ne sait pas
comment se sortir de cette situation
petite question subsidiaire nicolas
sarkozy doit-il quitter le conseil
constitutionnel vaudrait mieux c'est à
lui de voir
alors on va passer à l'autre volet
judiciaire de la semaine il concerne
jérôme cahuzac le ministre du budget
trois heures après l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire par le parquet de
paris notamment pour blanchiment de
fraude fiscale le président hollande a
décidé de mettre fin à ses fonctions
jérôme cahuzac est remplacé par bernard
cazeneuve la passation de pouvoir a
laissé un goût amer aux différents
ministres comme lui explique elisa
bartholomé passation de pouvoir
solennelle ce mercredi matin à bercy
attitude grave du ministre déchu jérôme
cahuzac ne mentionne pas l'enquète dont
il est l'objet et se contente d'un
passage du témoin amical à son
successeur bernard cazeneuve
mon ami bernard cette fois qu'elle
souhaite
découvrez la même passion et le même
bonheur gp pour une fonction qu'il est
obligé de quitter à cause de l' enquête
ouverte pour blanchiment de fraude
fiscale
une démission qui tombe mal en pleine
discussion sur les lettres de cadrage
bernard cazeneuve sait que la tâche qui
l'attend sera rude
on ne remplace pas jérôme cahuzac ou
cèdent modestement il a incarné dans
cette maison une grande compétence
une grande mais il ya forcé l'admiration
de son administration
émotion du ministre l'ancien poids lourd
du gouvernement quitte le ministère du
budget sous les applaudissements des
hauts fonctionnaires présents
beaucoup déplorent son départ jusqu'à
l'assemblée où les proches de jérôme
cahuzac salue un grand travailleur on
perd un ministre était quand même unique
ce trait au sud amène en termes de
compétences de brio d'autorité naturelle
et de combativité on perd un grand
ministre du budget il a remis les
comptes publics sur la bonne trajectoire
il laisse une maison propre mais dans
une situation difficile pour
mon côté jérôme cahuzac va maintenant se
consacrer à sa défense avant de
retrouver son siège de député
d'ici un mois il voit ce qu'il avait
vraiment le choix je prends ça comme
aller dans notre système actuel
médiatique pris les mêmes pas mis en
examen
1 dans notre système habituel
c'est une enquête préliminaire
évidemment ça fait la tuilerie
il démissionne pas ça fait pour qu'il ne
pouvait pas continuer comme ça sans
arrêt on nous aurait posé la question
donc on est on est dans cette situation
où la présomption d'innocence est
difficile à défendre parce que les gens
veulent savoir ce qui paraît tout à fait
normal mais qu'on est dans un système
totalement accusatoire et donc moi je
pense que jérôme cahuzac se défendra
qu'il en sortira la tête haute
dans quelque temps mais on aura perdu du
temps pour la france
un sacré coup porté à l'image des
politiques cette semaine avec diablement
évidemment évidemment il faut pas être
grand clerc pour comprendre qui va en
profiter
qui veulent l'abstention d'abord est
donc en par voie de conséquence le front
national et puis quand il faut profiter
de cette situation je ne pense pas tous
les extrêmes et tous ceux qui sont sur
la ligne tous pourris non à partir de là
évidemment et après on fera à nouveau et
gros titres mais comment se fait-il que
le front national progresse mais il
progresse parce que il y à de
l'irresponsabilité dans l'air parce que
on n'est pas capable de hiérarchiser les
problèmes parce que on travaille
aujourd'hui à reconstruire la france à
lui donner un nouveau pacte social comme
l'a fait le premier ministre l'a dit le
premier ministre dans la motion de
censure mais que ceux ci aient perturbé
par l'utilisation médiatique des
affaires responsabilités
la faute de qui la faute des politiques
à la faute de personne c'est
l'irresponsabilité canton et
d'irresponsables c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de responsabilité
ça ça vient comme cela parce que ça fait
partie d'un système aujourd'hui de bus
parisiennes qui s'enflamme régulièrement
sur des éléments qui sont très loin de
la préoccupation quotidienne qui peuvent
être graves et qui doivent être jugés
mais qui sont très loin des français
sont les juges qui font ce travail là ce
ne sont ni les journalistes ni grand
chose si je n'ai pas je n'ai pas mis en
cause ni les juges ni les gens lycées
génique c'est un système
c'est un système qui fonctionne comme
cela régulièrement qui s'autoalimente et
qui s'auto à lui même jean christophe
cambadélis
vous avez été condamné en 2006 dans l'
affaire de la mnef six mois de prison
avec sursis
vous disiez à l'époque la condamnation
était finalement pour vous un
soulagement parce qu'enfin c'était
derrière vous est ce que c'est quand
même quelque chose qu'on se traîne toute
sa vie politique
la preuve puisque vous fait l'amitié de
me le rappeler dont qu'on la prenne tout
le temps puisque sans arrêt on vous
renvoie même si il y a dix ans ou quinze
ans que les choses sont passées on est
toujours là à la merci d'une d'un rappel
dans l'adversaire politique ou d'un
journaliste aller mercredi lors du débat
de la motion de censure jean marc
ayrault avait tenu à rendre hommage à
son ancien ministre du budget puisque
évidemment au delà de cette affaire
c'est rayman hommes clés du gouvernement
que père jean marc ayrault
un homme au service de la france a dit
le premier ministre en écoute et je
salue en cet instant
jérôme cahuzac qui a fait preuve de
dignité et de responsabilité
en présentant hier sa démission je tiens
à le remercier ici pour son action
remarquable et courageuse au
gouvernement car il a été un excellent
ministre de budget au service de la
france
alors on a senti cette semaine le regret
de perdre un ministre compétent dans un
ministre incontournable et difficile
celui du budget c'est un homme qui va
manquer au redressement des comptes
publics
oui c'est un homme compétent qui avait
été déjà excellent
la commission financière des finances de
l'assemblée nationale qui était à la
fois excellent dans son exercice
ministériel est excellent il faut bien
le dire à l'assemblée nationale dans les
joutes oratoires
oui oui bah c'est quelqu'un qui est
entier donc quand on lui a fixé un cap
qui était celui de réduire nos déficits
publics et c'est au combien nécessaire
il s embrasser une partie un peu costaud
qui s'annonce la 5 milliards à trouver
de dépenses dans les ministères falloir
affronter les ministres pour faire
réduire leurs dépenses est ce que vous
pensez que bernard cazeneuve qui a fait
ses premiers pas cette semaine de miss
du budget sera capable d'affronter comme
ça avoir l'autorité pour affronter les
ministres mais c'est une autre forme
c'était un autre c'est un autre
personnage disant qu'il est il est plus
rond les plus diplomate et c'est alors
que plus douce et quelqu'un qui ont dans
les négociations et est inébranlable
1 on l'a vu dans le débat sur le traité
européen
mais je crois que une grande partie des
choses ont été faites puisque les
lettres de cadrage sont déjà arrivées
dans les ministères donc les ministres
savent à quoi s'en tenir
maintenant il s'agira de la pitié mais
cazeneuve représente un avantage je
dirais car il connaît très bien les
questions européennes
il y à un deuxième aspect qui va être
nécessaire c'est discuté avec bruxelles
de notre trajectoire est de convaincre
nos partenaires que nous arriverons
rapidement une souris trois personnes
qui va s'affronter un seul atterrir
angle entend retirer très rapidement se
mettre au fait sionnel oui donc c'est
d'abord il ya énormément de
deux responsables le ministre qui vont
l'aider et lui permettre très rapidement
de être au meilleur de sa forme dans ce
poste allez va reprendre un petit peu le
cours de cette semaine mardi un député
ps qu'il le dit pourquoi ne pas blesser
les allocations familiales pour les plus
riches
alors vous le savez actuellement les
allocations familiales sont versées à
tous les foyers à partir du deuxième
enfant à député ps gérard bapt propose
lui de les diviser par deux pour les
ménages les plus aisés une proposition
qui n'engage que lui dil ps rami cas
c'est l'un des piliers de la politique
familiale qui pourrait être ébranlé
celui les prestations familiales etc le
député ps gérard bapt qui en est à
l'origine
selon le rapporteur du budget de la
sécurité sociale
il faut réformer un système qui ne tient
plus si un déficit qui est détestable
parmi les déficits des branches de la
sécurité sociale c'est bien celui de la
branche famille puisqu'il s'agit de
prestations qui sont délivrés mois après
mois
aujourd'hui tous les foyers avec deux
enfants bénéficient d'allocations
familiales cette aide est attribuée sans
condition de ressources
et c'est ce que veut changer gérard bapt
il propose de diviser par deux les
allocations familiales des ménages les
plus aisés qui serait concerné par cette
réforme
les couples avec deux enfants dont les
revenus dépassent 50 2009 178 euros
et ce avec trois enfants dont les
revenus seraient au delà de 61000 335
euros par an autre allocation visé le
complément de mode de garde serait
supprimée pour les familles les plus
aisées
cette prestation est versée aux parents
selon leurs ressources pour la garde
d'enfants à domicile ou chez une
assistante maternelle
pour l'instant le gouvernement ne s'est
pas prononcé sur ces propositions mais
étudie les différentes possibilités pour
réformer le système
cette politique justement mérite
questionnements que c'est le but de l'as
de la mission de bertrand fragonard
qui a pour mission et attendant les
conclusions de son rapport de fournir
des indications sur une meilleure
efficience de notre système de politique
familiale
du côté de l'ump il n'est pas question
de toucher aux prestations familiales
pour combler le déficit de la branche
famille estimé à 2,6 milliards d'euros
ça n'est pas en matraquant les les
classes moyennes ce n'est pas en créant
de l'impôt tout azimut et ça n'est
surtout pas en matraquant les familles
comme ils veulent le faire
les deux pistes évoquées par gérard bapt
permettrait d'économiser 3 milliards
d'euros et devrait permettre de revenir
à l'équilibré dès 2016 alors est ce qu
on les réduit ou pas ses allocs
comment les appels écouter car les plus
riches cc oui pour une pas pour tout le
monde
bon c'est une proposition de gérard bapt
qui est un de nos parlementaires qui
connaît le mieux ces sujets il y a une
mission qui étudie différentes
possibilités en tout état de cause il va
falloir retourner à l' équilibre donc
les mêmes solutions se dit pas que ça
fait partie des bonnes solutions
une solution ce n'est pas de ne pas la
solution moi je veux pas de me rentrer
dans le concours lépine de la
proposition sur le sujet parce que ça
fait rebondir
on passe du temps c'est intéressant sur
ce sujet là alors que le gouvernement
n'a pas encore tranché
je crois qu'il vaudrait mieux attendre
pas très long que le rapport soit en
place
après on peut discuter entre nous et ça
va devoir décider mais je vois que à
chaque fois qu'on a une bonne idée fait
débat donc il faut s'interdire d'avoir
des idées au parti socialiste pourrait
faire débat non non non il faut savoir
faut avoir de bonnes idées il faut
parler à bon escient tout cas dans le
concours lépine y en a qu un fait une
assez étonnante c'est xavier bertrand
ancien ministre ump pourtant qui propose
de supprimer carrément les allocations
pour les vraiment plus riches
il est pas frileux lui oui les pas
frileux on se demande pourquoi il n'a
pas fait quand il était ministre
dans ce titre il sera seul coup il se
réveille pour nous faire ses
propositions c'est une proposition que
nous accueillerons dans l'ensemble des
propositions qui sont faites aujourd'hui
pour retourner à l'équilibré plus riches
les plus riches à partir de combien
est-ce qu'on est riche c'est un vrai
sujet j'espère que le rapport permettra
de répondre à cette question parce que
pour l'instant ce n'est pas fixée ce qui
est pas tout à fait à mon avis une
situation richissime
d'autant que aujourd'hui donc il ya
quand même beaucoup de paramètres qu'il
faut avoir en tête avant de aller mardi
toujours les députés ont adopté le
projet de loi sur la refondation de
l'école portée par le ministre vincent
peillon
adoptez donc la création de 60000 postes
supplémentaires d'ici 2017 ou encore le
rétablissement de la formation des
enseignants avec notamment des stages un
texte parasites et donc par les rythmes
scolaires qui ne sont pas dans le projet
de loi mais qui ont fait l'objet d'un
précédent décret cette semaine bertrand
delanoë a dit oui il appliquera à paris
lé 4 jours et demi dès 2013 mais en
revanche martine aubry a dit non la
réforme chez elle attendra 2014
et elle explique pourquoi nous voulons
prendre le temps à la fois de la
concertation et de l'aménagement dans
chaque école et le temps à la fois pour
trouver les bons intervenants et pour
les former si nécessaire et je pense
notamment aux nouvelles méthodes qui
permettent de poursuivre d'aller plus
loin dans ce que fait font les
enseignants sur le lire écrire compter
les acquis de base nous avons besoin de
temps de formation
si nous souhaitons que les intervenants
soient de qualité des parents insiste à
juste titre là dessus et bien évidemment
nous aussi donc il nous faut du temps
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'appliquerons cette réforme qu'en 2014
vous la connaissez bien martine aubry
vous êtes devenu l'un de ses soutiens à
l'occasion des primaires du ps
c'est un coup de pied de l'âne
le gouvernement c'est comme ça un petit
peu que ça a été fait mais c'est comme
ça que ça avec deux primés savez des
maires qui doivent réfléchir aux
meilleurs moyens d'agir
une grande ville comme paris a les
moyens financiers de son ambition de
faire cette réforme de tentations
d'impôts dit bien sûr mais parce que
nous avons les moyens c'est une très
grande ville ce qui n'est pas le cas des
autres qui doivent ajuster faire
attention mais il ya un espèce de débat
étonnant qui est qu'il faut absolument
que ce soit en 2013 et que en 2014 c'est
absolument une remise en cause de la loi
je ne comprends pas ce débat
pourquoi si le medef je n'en sais rien
vous faudra l'invité vous lui demanderez
on a eu un vote cette semaine qui me
semble extrêmement important qui permet
si ce n'est de refonder l'école de la
réorienter en direction des élèves et de
former les enseignants avec beaucoup
d'aspects la question des rythmes
scolaires est une question importante
mais qui n'est pas dans la réforme on
pouvait facilement dire 2013 2014 voire
2015 l'essentiel c'est que ça se fasse
c'est comme et formule des mandats un
pardon c'est un petit peu la main non je
pense que je pense je ne suis même pas
sûr je pense que il s'est dit ici on la
fait pas vite peut-être qu on la fera
pas bon je sais c'est de la base de son
raisonnement je suppose alors passer
cette forme mercredi
depuis le temps que l'on en parle ça y
est elle est là elle arrive
la motion de censure contre caen à
l'initiative de la motion de censure
jean françois copé se lance on ce
mercredi dans un long réquisitoire
contre la politique du gouvernement qui
dit il marche vers la bim
je sais où je vais lui et répond le
premier ministre dans le huis clos de
l'hémicycle et débats sont résumées par
jean mathis daoulas sa motion n'avait
aucune chance de faire tomber le
gouvernement
mais en françois copé en profite pour
livrer un réquisitoire d'une demi heure
le changement c'est maintenant chantier
vois-tu tête
et bien dites moi les français rêvent
que c'est maintenant que vous changiez
oui que vous changez de politique non
pas pour satisfaire l'orgueil de
l'opposition mais pour le bien de la
france
oh je ne vous demande pas de faire une
politique de droite je vous demande de
faire une bonne politique une politique
pour tous les français
quelques députés fillonistes reste assis
mais toute l'opposition ump applaudi
c'est l'image que jean françois copé
recherchait ce mercredi qui jean marc
ayrault lui répond à cinq reprises le
premier ministre assume un mot tabou la
rigueur je sais où je vais je sais
comment y parvenir
et comment faire mesdames et messieurs
les députés
je sais ce que doit être la france à la
fin de ce quinquennat
officiellement les centristes attendait
la réponse de jean marc ayrault pour
prendre leurs décisions sur la censure
un faux suspense ce que jean louis
borloo dissipe très rapidement
quel talent pour éviter de répondre à
toutes les questions que se posent les
français aient les deux groupes de
l'opposition
vous êtes en train de provoquer la plus
grande crise depuis la période de l'abbé
pierre
à gauche les alliés du ps font bloc avec
le gouvernement le ton est virulent chez
les écologistes
et puisque vous êtes permis de citer
georges pompidou
j'ai envie monsieur copé de le
paraphraser à mon tour en vous invitant
à cesser d'emmerdés l'assemblée par vos
manoeuvres incessantes d'obstruction et
de retardement
les communistes refusent de voter une
censure défendue par la droite mais il
en profite pour rappeler leurs critiques
au gouvernement
où sont les mesures attendues de
revalorisation des salaires et de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat des ménages
où sont les mesures de lutte contre les
licenciements boursiers et l'avidité des
actionnaires voilà la 55e motion de
censure de la vème république
rejeter une arme beaucoup plus
rhétorique que politique
alors donc comme l'a dit jean a dit sans
surprise la motion n'est pas acceptée
mais c'est pas le but l'exercice et donc
d'exercer son talent oratoire à la
tribune à qui attribuez vous les
meilleures notes vous allez dire jean
marc ayrault maire jean louis borloo a
été dans un registre baroque parce que
ils posaient les questions au premier
ministre il s'offusque et que celui ci
ne lui réponde pas mais ce n'était pas
l'objet de la motion de censure de
répondre aux grands mots donc c'était
une astuce mais il a été nettement
supérieure dans le fond et dans la forme
ah ah
jean françois copé qui ont peu pour
reprendre ce terme qui applaudissent et
jaune quand il a vu le succès de borloo
au sein de l'ump qui s'est levé d'un
seul coup à la fin de l'intervention
mais surpris jean marc ayrault
oui moi je trouvais qu'il était mais
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se passe depuis
quelques mois ils étaient solides
il est le raison de dire qu'il savait où
il allait donc ça voulait dire ouais
parce que vous avez une espèce de bronca
sur lui c'était le plus petit
dénominateur commun est petit à petit
voilà donc je devais à petit sa firme je
trouve il se bonifie
il devient de plus en plus clair il fixe
un cas et il a développé une idée qui à
mon avis n'a pas été reprise parce qu'on
a été occupée par beaucoup d'autres
choses dans le quart d'heure suivant à
savoir qu'ils accusaient depuis
maintenant 20 nicolas sarkozy tient une
refondation de notre contrat social dans
une époque tout à fait nouvelle qui est
celle de la mondialisation et de la
crise a quand même prononcé pendant
cette fois le mot rigueur c'est un mot
qui n'est désormais plus tabou on se
souvient qu'à une époque on contourne
est le mot de mille façons alors vous
avez vu qu' il y a une astuce dans son
texte c'est que il s'impose une rigueur
de de gouvernement il ne s'agit pas de
la politique d'austérité
donc bon je pense que l'austérité c'est
quelque chose de très particulier
si on peut faire 15 secondes dessus
vérité c'est le blocage des salaires
c'est la réduction des pins de des
pensions c
la réduction au niveau des retraites etc
c'est quelque chose qui se passe en
espagne au portugal voire en grèce mais
ne se passe pas en france pas
aujourd'hui est ce que vous estimez
classe est un tournant ce qu'on a eu ce
discours de jean marc ayrault
il affirme définitivement son côté
social démocrate oui parce qu'il a
beaucoup parlé de sa méthode est elle
paye que ce soit sur la question des
retraites ou sur la sécurisation 20 ce
qui peut conduire à la sécurisation des
parcours professionnels c'est-à-dire la
loi que nous allons en discuter au mois
d'avril
je crois que ça c'est de lui c'est de
lui c'est ça c'est sa pensée depuis très
longtemps qu'on pourrait faire son
histoire d'ailleurs puisqu'il était
pauvre et nist et il était pour ce
contrat social cette discussion
social-démocrate entre les partenaires
sociaux
je pense qu'il va gagner un petit peu de
l'autre côté sur votre gauche aussi non
le sac n'est pas la méthode team était
mise en cause c'est le résultat
c'est le résultat parce que ici ou là on
pense qu'on devrait aller beaucoup plus
loin sur tel ou tel sujet mais la
difficulté c'est que quand vous êtes
dans un dans une négociation entre
partenaires sociaux
c'est eux qui fixent le graveleux ce
centre de gravité à la fin c'est pas
vous donc évidemment là il ya une
difficulté à comprendre ce que c'est que
cette démarche nécessaire en france de
négociations entre les partenaires
sociaux
alors autre sujet autre thème est ce que
vous avez voté oui pour le mariage pour
tous mais pourquoi je souffre non c'est
une question parce que le projet lui il
arrive au sénat ça sera discuté des
urines ça vous le savez et il vient
d'être adopté en commission des lois le
vote positif a été obtenu grâce à deux
voix de l'ump explications gerbe rabier
il aura fallu presque quatre heures de
réunion pour que la commission des lois
adopte le texte sur le mariage pour tous
pas question de voter le même projet
qu'à l'assemblée nationale un parfait
juridiquement selon les sénateurs mais
au final la philosophie du texte reste
la mer je pense que le texte tel qu'il
sens de la commission des lois
aujourd'hui est amélioré techniquement
et juridiquement le périmètre est le
même c'est le mariage ouvert aux couples
de même sexe
l'adoption simple l'adoption plénière ni
plus ni moins des détails techniques
comme le choix du nom de l'enfant en cas
d'adoption ont été votées mais les
amendements sur la pma ou la gpao comme
attendu été rejetée pas d'obstruction de
l'ump comme à l'assemblée mais une
contre proposition
objet d'un amendement de 20 pages
défendue par le groupe parlementaire à
côté du mariage quelques il existe on
mettait en place une union civile qui
devait répondre à toutes les mêmes
droits mêmes devoirs que dans le mariage
mais avec seulement une différence et
qui avait pas de prolongations sur la
filiation ou sur l'adoption
une proposition non retenu par la
majorité qui reste attachée au terme
mariage et adoption à 23 voix contre 21
une le texte a finalement été adoptée de
radicaux de gauche n'ont pas participé
au vote et fragiliser la faible majorité
mais deux sénateurs ump de la commission
des lois ont finalement voté en faveur
du texte
il faut trouver un équilibre de la part
des choses et voir ma conviction de
législateur était au dessus de ma
collection personnelle je n'ai pas
imposer ma conviction personnelle aux
autres je dois constater qu' un certain
nombre de coupes qui ont besoin de cela
pour être heureux la prochaine bataille
aura lieu dans la rue dimanche avec le
défilé parisien des anti mariage pour
tous avant la dernière étape à la haute
assemblée à partir du 4 avril pour
l'examen en séance du projet de loi les
sénateurs conte à l'interroger mais qui
pas forcément dans ce reportage nous
disent mais on va falloir re écrit hier
ce qu'ont fait les députés parce qu'il
ya des manques il y à même selon une
note parue dans le figaro un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité
vous savez c'est un grand classique
chaque assemblée c'est dément quand même
oui enfin bon on verra ça quand il y
aura la commission mixte paritaire entre
l'assemblée et le sénat puis une
deuxième lecture sera bon mais
l'essentiel honnêtement c'est qu'au bout
il mariage pour tous et l'adoption donc
que l'on se borde juridiquement pour ne
pas être retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel très bien je ne suis pas
certain que ce qui a été proposé soit
praticable sur le plan juridique nous on
va voir on va discuter
pas de problème est étonné que ce texte
fasse encore débat qui encore des
manifestations de rue etc
quand je ne suis pas étonné parce que il
y a dans notre société les gens qui ne
veulent pas ces évolutions sont les
mêmes qui étaient défavorables à
l'avortement
ou à d'autres éléments d'évolution de
notre société
et quand on sait que ça sera voté de
toute façon on se dit que pourquoi
autant qu'en de manifestations pourquoi
autant de bruit parce que je crois que
jusqu'au bout on doit
c'est comme ça quand on mène une lutte
jusqu'au bout on pense que il est
possible de retourner la situation
alors on parla du conseil
constitutionnel on va en reparler
puisqu'on va passer au jeudi et la taxe
à 75% qui a du plomb dans l aile
françois hollande n'a décidément pas de
chance avec sa taxe à 75% sur les très
hauts revenus retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel
sa nouvelle version a également fait
l'objet d'un avis négatif ou devrait
faire l'objet d'un avis négatif du
conseil d'état car considérés comme
confiscatoire une mesure qui rapporte
peu mais très clairement une mesure
symbole jean baptiste daoulas d'accès à
75 % les revenus supérieurs à un million
d'euros
une promesse choc de la campagne de
françois hollande qui pourrait ne jamais
se concrétiser
d'après le journal le figaro le conseil
d'état devrait en dissuader le
gouvernement
motif invoqué la barre des 75% serait
jugée confiscatoire par le conseil
constitutionnel avec à la clé une
nouvelle loi censurée pour ne pas
prendre ce risque
le conseil d'état a une solution ramener
la taxation de 75 à 66 % sur 5 6% c'est
déjà beaucoup quand même cesser les deux
tiers 1 du salaire
donc c'est déjà beaucoup mais il
s'agissait effectivement d'un symbole
vous avez raison et ce symbole doit être
mise en oeuvre soit 66 sous forme d'un
impôt 75 sur une taxe dont
s'acquitteraient les entreprises le but
c'est que ça s'arrête
c'est que ça se calme autre avis du
conseil d'état
la taxe ne pourra pas concerner
uniquement les revenus du travail
les revenus du capital devront aussi
être concernés enfin pour les personnes
en couple
la taxe ne pourra pas s'appliquer à elle
seule mais à leur foyer fiscal dans son
ensemble reste à déterminer si la taxe
s'appliquera pour un couple à partir de
un ou deux millions d'euros de revenus
le but c'est que ça s'arrête dit
christian eckert
je comprends on passerait donc à un taux
de 66%
quelques avec une assiette plus large
incluant les revenus du capital
c'est bien ça c'est une bonne formule
qu'est-ce qu'il est difficile en france
de s'attaquer aux plus riches
c'est difficile toujours on est toujours
devant des grandes difficultés et ils
ont des trésors des deux d'action pour
empêcher qu'on est les taxes d'arguments
du confiscatoire à votre avis n'est pas
un argument titre ce n'est pas pour moi
ça c'est pas un argument je dire quand
on est dans la situation telle qu'on la
connaît quand on connaît le nombre de
chômeurs des exclus dans notre société
je ne dis pas que il faut tout réduire
et égaliser enfin demander un effort aux
plus riches c'est quand même pas
confiscatoire
mais on va voir parce que pour l'instant
on n'est que dans la rumeur moi je n'ai
pas vu ce texte du conseil d'état seul
organe de presse là
évoquée est pas publiés donc on va voir
peut-être que c'est une solution mais il
faut la serait d'accord avec le
rapporteur du budget il faut faire
maintenant assez vite c'est un pardon un
impôt qui rapporte peu 1 500 - et ce que
je disais tout à l'heure et ça concerne
très peu de personnes évidemment donc
allonger qu'on a entendu parce qu'ils
aient du moment il a été beaucoup de
choses il se dit ça je m'attendais
recommandations du conseil
constitutionnel mais aussi à la décision
du conseil d'état est ce que vous
estimez que cette que cette loi a été
mal préparée je suis trop vite ce n'est
peut-être pas dans la campagne
non parce que c'était une indication et
que au moment où elle a été présentée
par le candidat françois hollande elle a
été forte utile mais connaisseur des
dérailleurs fiscalité puisqu'elle était
ou non le conseil constitutionnel
mais de bâtir de vous savez moi j'ai eu
j'ai réagi on me l'a reproché quand le
conseil constitutionnel a pris position
en disant qu'un conseil constitutionnel
qui est composé essentiellement de gens
désignés par leurs prédécesseurs de
droite évidemment et sur la ligne
idéologique et pas simplement juridique
de du côté confiscatoire de l'impôt pour
les plus riches donc évidemment à partir
de là mais sacré à la fois un fait
juridique et une orientation politique
j'avais dit je veux dire aujourd'hui
bien sûr c'est un coup politique
derrière tout cela bon alors après essai
il faut prendre en compte ce qui a été
dit et essayer de ne pas se faire
retoquer une deuxième fois
alors on va passer peut-être à la bonne
nouvelle de la semaine mais il en faut
quand même au moins une
et bien c'est la plus grosse commande de
l'histoire de l'aviation civile qui a
été conclu à l'elysée dans les salons de
l'elysée pour airbus la signature de
près de 234 avions a320 pour un montant
de plus de 18 milliards d'euros françois
hollande
évidemment s'en est réjoui il avait le
sourire au moment de la signature signé
dans les salons
dix essais un peu quand même
communication entre et que tout va bien
non jean christophe cambadélis montre
pas que tout va bien mais oui mais moi
je pense que c'était un des éléments au
début de l'intervention du premier
ministre il trouvait ça très très juste
c'est que on est sans arrêt on entend
sans arrêt le discours du pessimisme le
discours d' une france rabougrie d'une
france qui n'y arrivent pas d'une france
qui n'est pas capable
l'exemple c'est tellement mieux en
allemagne c'est tellement mieux en
angleterre c'est tellement mieux aux
états unis c'est tellement mieux dans
taux de dans d'autres pays
et c'est toujours mal en france bon
france nous avons des sept enfants
cd et cd c'était nous avons des
ingénieurs c'est une coopération
européenne et il faut le souligner cela
montre que l'europe dans la
mondialisation peut être compétitive que
le président de la république souhaite
le souligner pour montrer qu'il y à une
france et une europe qui gagne moi je
trouvais ça très bien parmi toutes les
semaines on est content merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous sur dans cette
émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine si vous voulez bien
une fois de plus